le pire est à venir loana interview
expliqué à ma fille
non non si votre petite fille qui parle
par ma bouche
comme dans l'exorciste
dit maman il est où papa y en a pas il
n'a pas voulu de toi
dis maman c'est qu'ils jean-edouard
je te montre america 7 y compris
dis maman tu m'aimes bien suivi
oui j'aime beaucoup et baffie tulle aime
bien jusque là ça va on verra plus tard
et hardy sont très sains allumeuse
dis maman comment on fait les bébés
ce peuple est à 30 ans à grandes banques
tu m'expliqueras louana
dis maman pourquoi le monsieur qui vient
des fois la maison il tombera sur la
bouche
ah
parce que parce qu'il aime beaucoup
pourquoi ne voit plus tout le temps à la
télé parce que je préfère m'occuper de
toi m'a
dit maman
le monsieur qui est embrasse tout le
temps sur la bouche il a fait la même
chose à la baby sitter
il a pu revenir les messieurs c'est bine
dit là bas j'en
dis maman on va rester toujours ensemble
maintenant
yassia et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de 1h10 tube abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus